Riverdale is an undeniable hit and
there's a lot about the show that really
works when it's firing on all cylinders
as with anything though there are also
plenty of things that don't quite land
to appreciate them both
it's time to talk about the best and the
worst things about the show one of the
reasons Archie comics have endured for
so long as their reliance on broad
character archetypes if you take
characters with clear-cut traits and
apply them in the right way you can
essentially tell a story in any genre
you want the TV series has embraced this
from the very beginning and the result
is a show nimble enough to pivot between
horror comedy musical and crime drama
often within the space of a single
episode the flexibility with which
Riverdale can dip into many different
genres and themes means it can also
successfully juggle many different plots
at once when this is done right you get
an extremely satisfying story with a
long arc in just the right amount of
tension unfortunately season two's black
hood story wasn't quite so well juggled
it seemed to wrap up midway through the
season only to be clumsily rolled out
again for an even bigger reveal later on
sometimes Riverdale should let these
things go sooner Riverdale ostensibly
has four main characters or at least it
did when it started Archie Betty Jughead
and Veronica they're the two guys in two
girls who ultimately formed the two
couples at the heart of the show while
everyone else around them serves a
supporting role however one supporting
character has become absolutely
essential the majestic and deliciously
venomous Cheryl blossom played by
Madeline Peck
mr. Rogers nice haircut looking
extremely dilthey today is our deal
cheryl enters the series as the spoiled
rich girl who gets to be the center of
attention because her brother died and
ultimately evolves into so much more
patches gloriously indulgent performance
means cheryl also gets to steal pretty
much every scene she's in listen up
ragamuffins i will not allow a real
highs above average GPA to suffer
because of classrooms that are
overcrowded with underachievers this is
a character who can introduce herself
without a hint of irony as Riverdale's
resident it girl in one scene and then
melt your heart with vulnerability in
the next she's just that good
one of the very first things we learn
about Riverdale's version of Archie
Andrews football star and resident good
boy of Riverdale high school is that
he's been having an affair with one of
his teachers it's a sexy unexpected
element that adds a little hint of
danger to a character we think we know
and it sets Archie off on a promising
path to being much more than the Queen
cut boy next door in the years since
then
Archie's become even darker and so
Archie always trying to do the good
noble thing took another step further
into darkness and yet despite all these
steps into darkness he still remains the
least interesting main character on a
show in which he's supposed to be the
lead when the first footage of Riverdale
arrived many viewers were quick to
compare its visual tone to Twin Peaks
David Lynch and Mark Frost legendary TV
show
indeed Riverdale's first major storyline
did seem pretty Twin Peaks
esque the show's drifted even farther
into the horrific in season two and it's
made Riverdale even more fun to watch
its killings the main Riverdale cast
aside there's another group of key
supporting players josie and the
pussycats the trouble is when
Riverdale's version of josie often has a
bigger role to play as a supporting cast
member the Pussycats as a unit don't get
used very often even in some of the
show's more music heavy moments they're
pushed aside in favor of the main cast
which is a real shame hopefully they get
more to do in future episodes this year
we'd like to build on that success
continue telling our story with songs we
write Riverdale is a show packed with
high stakes stories a murder needs to be
solved a vigilante is roaming the
streets there's a gang war brewing on
the south side it works both because of
the show's sincere desire to tell these
stories and all their juicy soapy glory
and because of its commitment to
remaining tongue-in-cheek about just how
Sofia can get that means that in
addition to deeply emotional and even
terrifying moments we get dark Betty in
a black wig or Cheryl bringing the
cheerleading squad to a funeral in a
tire that could best be described as
spirit mourning
Riverdale is never afraid to have fun
with itself and that makes it more
enjoyable all around when he was first
introduced Jughead Jones was the kind of
Greek chorus of Riverdale a narrator
filling in the viewer on the shows
various shenanigans
I'm the damaged loner outsider from the
wrong side of the tracks
then as the Jason blossom story wound
down
Jughead became a guy who got mixed up in
his father's biker gang and has been one
of the strangest characters on the show
since then and the characters on words
I'm weird I'm a weirdo I don't fit in
and I don't want to fit in have you ever
seen me without the stupid hat on that's
weird
[Music]